I'm joined today by Scott page who is
the leonid hurwicz collegiate professor
of complex systems at the university of
michigan also author of the recently
released book the diversity bonus and I
found the book very very interesting
Scott let's just start with trying to
define some terms here how do we measure
the bonus to businesses of more
diversity and what types of diversity
are we talking about so the way we
measure it is we just sort of ask how
much better does a team do when that
team is diverse versus a team that's
homogeneous and what I mean by diversity
here is I mean cognitive diversity
differences and how people think
differences in perspectives tools
training that sort of stuff that's going
to be related to identity diversity
sometimes very directly sometimes
indirectly but what really produces
these bonuses better predictions better
solutions is different ways of thinking
so one of the sort of ways to refute
arguments from some that there is sort
of an inherent caused by race difference
in IQ is that the differences in IQ
within races are far bigger than the
average differences between races what
about when it comes to cognitive
diversity can we make any kind of
analogy in the sense that does the do
the differences in cognitive diversity
vary more between different types of
diversity and identity groups or within
them I think that's a great question
that probably depends a little bit by
subject area so you'll hear people say
we value cognitive diversity and then
have all white man right so you can have
cognitive diversity among a group of all
white men but probably not as much now
if we're looking in an engineering
problem or a math problem the role that
identity plays in cognitive diversity
may be lower than if we're thinking
about health care policy or designing a
car or you know writing a screenplay or
something like that right the extent to
which our identities can affect how we
think about something he's gonna you
know obviously kind of bury by tap so
let's take one of the examples that you
said that this type of diversity would
be more noticeable when we talk about
designing a car for example or feel free
to pick whatever what
for example you think is sort of
illustrative of what you're talking
about
in what ways would we see that diversity
bone is reflected you know so again so
we've a woman's designing a car she's
gonna ask you know possibly where am I
gonna put my purse not to stereotype
right if someone who lives in the
suburbs for the larger families
designing a car they're gonna ask you
know does my dog fit in here writers dog
hair gonna get stick somebody could come
up with some seat that looks comfortable
but it could be like I'm never gonna get
the dog hair out of this right someone
who spends a lot of time you know
drinking coughing the car is gonna ask
you know where is my cupholders so the
thing is depending on you know who you
are and how you roll you're gonna you
know want different attributes in your
car you're gonna think about different
things is there a particular kind of
diversity that seems to be more helpful
than others in terms of race versus
gender versus economic background
whatever attribute we're talking about
so when you look at science and you ask
you know okay what you know
breakthroughs in science are
increasingly done by teams so if you
look at sort of most scientific papers
most academic papers are done by teams
the two things that really seem to sort
of move the needle or you know where
were you trained in so you don't get me
so what exactly is your knowledge base
and then the other thing that way seems
to matter is can like where did you
learn it so going to different schools
really produces a bonus so the three
sort of you know and then identities
probably the third thing so you know
what do you know where did you learn it
and who are you are kind of the three
big contributors to diversity bonuses
how could we separate causation from
correlation when we talk about something
like the business impact of diversity in
the sense that I could imagine that
companies that have a more diverse labor
force might do better because of some
other thing like for example more
dollars spent on recruitment and it's
not because of the diversity itself but
because of some third or other factors
how can we separate that out I think
that's actually you know difficult to do
in general and social science we
struggle you know separating out cause
agents and correlation one of the one of
the interesting things I've found over
the last decade have visited lots of
different organizations and you know for
profits nonprofits one thing you find is
that places that sort of embrace
identity diversity also embrace
cognitive diversity because they've got
a culture in which difference is
accepted so one of things that really
matters in terms of sort of getting
these diversity bonuses if is someone
being willing to share a novel idea so
when we say hey have we thought about
this so the episode of a culture of fear
or a culture in which everybody's forced
to sort of like you know just repeat the
company line you're not gonna get these
bonuses and so you're right it could be
the case that the presence of identity
diversity is really just sort of a
signal of the fact that this is a place
where people feel comfortable and the
people feel comfortable they're more
likely to share ideas the other thing
that's interesting about identity
diversity and this is work by Katherine
Phillips who also contributed to this
book I wrote is that if I'm in an
identity diverse group I often feel more
compelled to fully explain myself and
when I do that I might either I might or
someone else might see a flaw in my
logic so if you bunch of all white male
economists in a room they don't like you
sort of like Oh mark it's work people
are rational right throw in a woman
psychologist and then they're kind of
like well let me explain why people are
rational when as they walk through that
they might say yeah maybe this is an
emotional purchase or maybe they're not
that rational or maybe they're thinking
about other things so the mere presence
of diversity can cause you to sort of
think differently and get better answers
so so far we've been talking mostly
about what would be on the sort of pro
side of workplace diversity what about
or how do we deal with the
counter-arguments like for example
without diversity you eliminate
diversity based discrimination as
something that can be a weight on the
day-to-day functioning of a business or
team or you eliminate some degree of
cultural incongruity or whatever how can
we measure the sort of net effect let's
grant all of the pros that you've
identified how do we then back out and
consider the possible cons of diversity
that some might point to oh so the cons
are there so if you want someone to say
oh all diversity all the time like I'm
not your guy but here's how I think
about this is that on a day to day sort
of rolling basis any organization is
gonna have some complex problems and
some easy problems
I'm the easier problems
you're kind of better off going
homogeneity because there's not gonna be
any diversity bonus so in the book I
talk a lot about kind of like chopping
down trees if we're chopping down trees
there's no diversity bonus right but if
we're curing cancer there's a big
diversity bonus so what you want to do
is you kind of want to do this is what I
call sort of a complexity diversity
triage when the problem comes in the
door you got to decide is this a
high-value complex problem and if it is
you throw the diversity at it right and
you hope the benefits outweigh the cost
if it's simple you just give it to
somebody and let them handle it but if
you don't have that diversity in house
if you haven't built a culture if you
haven't built sort of protocols where
you can get those diversity bonuses then
you're gonna screw up the high-value
complex problems and you're gonna go
under you can see this one the places
where you see this go into an emergency
room if you like twisted your ankle
somebody looks at you and they say
simple may hand you off to someone who
tapes it up and they send you home if
you're presenting in some really
complicated confusing way they're gonna
walk you past a whole bunch of different
doctors then a group of doctors will
meet then they'll come back and look at
you and ask a bunch of questions and you
get a very sophisticated complex
diagnosis it comes at a higher cost
absolutely but the point is it's a more
important problem like you're not gonna
die from a twisted ankle and so this is
I view this really is about diversity as
a strategic asset so if you have the
culture and the people in house to apply
cognitive diversity right then the
challenge is identifying those tasks
where you use it and let's say you
haven't yet built this diverse team what
are ways to do that effectively I mean
we've I've done some research into
so-called diversity policies there's
been this recent one with this former
Google engineer James the more he
criticized the diversity policy it
became his whole thing I don't need you
to comment on that necessarily unless
you want to but there is a longitudinal
study of 700 US companies which found
that diversity training programs and
policies did not really seem to have a
net positive effect specifically when it
came to the representation of that one
looked at black women for example so
talked a little bit about diversity
policies and what are effective ways to
increase diversity okay so if you look
at the societal level right there's just
gonna be there's gonna be some
percentage of people in each of these
identity categories that's graduated
from college
is gonna be sort of on-boarded into
corporate America on-boarded into sort
of government agencies and it's not that
maybe sort of in some sense kind of like
zero-sum in a way right people are gonna
go work one place maybe not another
place but if you look across all
industries you know you they it's not
necessarily possible that they could all
work unless you sort of create more
people in one of these categories I
think though what you really want to ask
is are these diverse teams functioning
well and producing better you know sort
of producing pragmatic benefits within
these organizations and one of the
things that you find and this is sort of
you know gripped by David Thomas and
Robin Ely at Harvard and Jeff polls are
at Harvard beta Maddox at Cornell is
that if people think that the diversity
is there because it's the right thing to
do
you're not gonna see bonuses but you're
not gonna see big benefits from it but
if people think the diversity is there
because it gives you benefits you're
likely to see the benefit because you
kind of get what you're asking for right
if you're thinking like well you look
different than me you were trained
different with me you're from a
different place you can probably help me
if that's how I approach you
odds are we may get something positive
from that but if instead of my glue
David you're kind of different for me
you look different from me okay I'll be
nice to you because I'm inclusive we're
not likely to see anything really
exciting yet that makes sense but who is
it that would have one or the other of
those perspectives is it managers is it
people in HR deciding on hiring is it
colleagues like who is it that would
have the possibility of either relating
to diversity as something we're supposed
to do or something that genuinely
improves the team I think this is what
it really comes from the top from
leadership from the top and corporate
cultures I think you had a time when
most when a lot of the workforce that
capped the workforce in the 1960 was
engaged in sort of you know physical
labor manufacturing sort of jobs jobs
that didn't produce these bonuses that
affirmative action programs diversity
programs were framed in terms of
inclusiveness like let's be inclusive
let's not discriminate I think when you
move to the knowledge economy if you go
to Ford if you go to Google if you go to
Northrop Grumman right if you go to
Bloomberg you're gonna see leadership
talking about the necessity having
cognitively diverse people working on
hard problems so Astro teller at Google
X which is kind of like you know
stretch out for an innovative place you
know he sounds like an HR diversity
person when he talks about human capital
he's like we need people who think
differently we need people with diverse
perspective and so I think that it
really comes from the top but then it
also has to be you know sort of carried
out within the protocols of the firm the
book is the diversity bonus we've been
speaking with the book's author
University of Michigan professor Scott
page Scott very interesting and I really
appreciate you talking to us about it
thanks a lot it's great opportunity
thank you